more than 10 million people in the UK
are either receiving pensions from a
so-called defined benefit scheme or
expecting to for many of them the
currents uncertainty has been a
significant worry well here to answer
your questions is Tom Selby head of
retirement policy at AJ Bell Chief
European Economist at Bloomberg and
former official at the treasury and
Claire Scott divisional director of
retirement and holistic planning at St
James Place wealth management and I
don't think I said your name Jamie rush
so thanks very much indeed for joining
us tonight and we've had so many
questions you know I mean my pages are
full people are incredibly worried about
this uh obviously of course let's start
with this question from Susan who says
um could this economic crisis take all
my private pension I've already seen it
reduce by about seven thousand pounds
and Tom Selby let's start with you
so no
um there there shouldn't be a risk of
anyone losing all of their pensions I
think one of the one of the more
damaging things about what we've seen in
this crisis is actually that pensions
have been dragged into it at all so the
problem that the bank of England has
been trying to deal with is a sell-off
of government bonds now pensions have
been dragged into that because defined
benefit pensions are big holders of
government bonds and we're potentially
going to sell off a lot of them but in
terms of the safety of people's private
pensions what we're seeing here is going
to make no difference whatsoever except
for people who are highly invested in
government bonds that'll be a very very
small number of people the vast majority
of people are going to be absolutely
fine the key thing for divine benefit
pensions is the solvency the the safety
of the employer that stands behind the
guarantee as long as that employer
remains in place and it has a legal duty
to pay the pensions that it's promised
you so provided the employer is still
there then your pension will be safe
even in that extreme scenario of the
employer going bust there's the pension
protection fund which stands as a safety
net to stand behind those pension
promises if something does go wrong
okay
um Claire Trott
um I Abe is asking is it best to freeze
my pension investment account until
things settle
well it really depends what they mean by
freeze I mean it's not really possible
to freeze your pension in that so
there's a there's a lot of things you
see that are there that say my pension
is frozen which people mean when they
leave well that isn't actually what
happens even in the defined benefits
Arena
um they will continue to grow dependent
on the rules of the scheme if you were
to opt out of the scheme but obviously
at the scheme just means that you're not
building up any more benefits
um and and actually that's really going
to be a detriment in the long run to
your pension planning if what you mean
if you're actually invested in the stock
market should I put it all in cash well
again that's a really difficult decision
to make because the stock market
fluctuates it's a long-term investment
and by putting it in cash all you're
going to get is interest if you're lucky
depending on how you you put it in there
so it's a big risk to to actually make
any rash decisions about anything at
this point
um the the key would be to get
individual advice for you personally
um to look at what your pension is how
it's invested uh how long you've got to
retirement if it's a defined benefit
um as as Tom said it's it's protected
under a variety of different regimes so
firstly by the employer and then by the
ppf so opting out is rarely like to be
in your favor yeah I I guess people are
also concerned that maybe
um with the cost of living crisis
putting less into the pension when that
pension might also go but that's very
Sound Advice Claire thanks for that um
let's uh take this question about
um government guilds um and we'll bring
you in now Jamie um Mike is asking will
government guilt settle down and still
be a safe investment for pensions uh uh
what's your assessment Jamie do you
think government guilts will settle down
um it depends very much on on what the
government does over the next few months
over the next few weeks and months
um the reason we have a problem is that
the the markets have lost faith in the
in the government's competence
um they think that the fiscal plans are
irresponsible and so they need more
compensation to hold uh a whole guilt
that the debt of the government uh
issues now there are a couple ways
forward one possibility is that he might
use u-turn on the the tax measures that
have been announced at the giveaways
um that would win credibility with
markets most likely and probably help to
bet down borrowing costs for the
government to some extent the other
possibility is he spells out a large
package of spending cuts perhaps
um that may not be viewed as credible in
markets and that might not solve the
problem for for guilds so I think you
know the right now most people in
markets are expecting that government
borrowing costs are going stay very high
and therefore the value of those guilts
in your pension portfolio is has been
reduced and there's there's a
possibility that will be permanent
okay
um let's take a question from
um Neil who says I have an invested
pension pot which is seeing large losses
in value is there a risk I could lose
everything that that's the same concern
that I'm sure many of you watching are
having an asking again
um uh Tom let's bring you in again
you're saying that it doesn't matter
what kind of pension you have there's no
risk of losing it is that or not
so there shouldn't be a risk of you
losing everything so we've got two
different types of pension scheme here
that people are talking about and again
I think one of the the challenges with
this is that people are reading
headlines saying pensions crisis and
they assume it affects all type of
Pensions and it doesn't so we've got
defined benefit pensions where the key
thing is that the employer is solvent
and has to stand behind the promise
regardless of what happens under the
Bonnet of that pension scheme and as I
said the pension protection fund exists
as a safety net even if that sponsoring
employer goes bust you've then got
defined contribution pensions where your
money's invested and again only those
people who are very heavily invested in
government bonds will be seeing Big
Falls in the value of their pensions
most people will be invested in a
diverse range of Investments all around
the world and so what's happening in the
UK it's a very UK specific problem we're
seeing here now lots of people will be
will have experienced investment Falls
over the past 12 months over the past 24
months but that's part and parcel of
long-term investing if you're investing
in a pension your time Horizon is going
to be over decades rather than a few
months or a couple of years so you
should be able to ride out any
uncertainty we've got at the moment with
the aim of achieving that long-term
growth over time
right but interesting you say that so
let's pick up this question then because
this flows nicely into it um Tom and all
of you of course Jackie is saying I see
my private pension dropping lately I
have under five years until I retire so
clearly she's worried this is coming
soon should I take my pension now
um Tom look we'll pick up because you
were mentioning that you know you should
be able to ride it out that's five years
away should she take it now
uh it depends what she means by take it
so I can't give individual advice based
on people's own personal circumstances
but there are various dangers if you
just take all of your pension out now so
you'll potentially end up paying more
tax than you might otherwise do because
you could push yourself up into a higher
tax bracket you're also taking your
money out of a very tax efficient
environment and you might potentially be
shoving it in a bank account for example
and you might be earning very little or
no interest on that money whatsoever I'd
I'd suggest if anyone who is suffering
Big Falls in their Investments at the
moment needs to have a think about what
their investment priorities are now it's
possible that this person is invested in
what's known as an annuity hedging fund
so that means that the as someone
approaches retirement and plans to
secure an income with an insurance
company which is what an annuity is
they'll move into bonds which move in
the opposite direction to annuity rate
so if the plan is to buy an annuity then
what they'll be experiencing is a fall
in their fund value but the level of
annuity they'll be able to buy with that
in with with that fund will be
increasing so if that's the case then
the fall in the fund value isn't
necessarily something to be concerned
about the area let me bring in sorry Tom
let me bring in um uh Claire here
because Claire I expect you're getting a
lot of similar questions to this at the
moment you know what should I do should
I pull out should I stay the course
um and stuff like that and I'm going to
tack on another question uh Claire which
is from uh ADI which says what actions
can I take to protect my pension so if
you bring in
the last question and and what actions
people can take to protect their pension
Claire
yes certainly I mean a totally agree
with Tom I mean there's there's so many
different things going on here that we
can't give individual advice over over
this very short period of time and um as
I mentioned earlier you know
personalized advice even personalized
guidance from the available bodies to
talk about what your options are with
your pensions can really add value
um to try and understand where you're
sitting in the market as well as when
you're coming to retirement
um it really depends on as Tom said what
you're planning to do a lot of people
it's not a it's not just an annuity that
people are looking at these days people
are looking at taking retirement over
many many years changing their working
pattern reducing their hours just taking
a little bit here and there and taking
that little bit just because you need it
it's not going to suddenly impact you
know all your Investments but moving to
possibly you know less risky Investments
if that's appropriate for you or as you
say taking a little bit and writing out
the keeping the rest of it invested but
take it all out or putting it all in
cash is is actually a really extreme
move in these markets when we're seeing
drops or fluctuations because something
happens one day could bounce back the
next day I'll take you all the way back
to covid we had massive drops in the
market on one day and by the end of the
week we were back to normal I'm
expecting this might be a little bit
long longer but we don't know what's
going to happen we don't know what's
going to come out on the 31st of October
when we get the the statements uh from
the chancellor and things will change
and things might change quite quickly so
making any rash decisions now about
changing your Investment Portfolio or
taking money out of Pensions could have
a real detrimental effect to your
long-term planning and pensions are long
term we may only have five years until
you retire but that's five years till
you start drawing an income not five
years until your money runs out
um or until worst case scenario you we
all will eventually die
um and that's when we want our pensions
to run out at the point of death or you
know leave a little bit for for our
beneficiaries in the long run so it's
not a case of what do I need to do
before I hit that date where I want to
stop work it's considering that and the
longer term and how you're going to fund
it over all that period so there's
there's lots of things to consider and
it's not just the case of I've got a
date in mind and I need to work towards
that anymore
okay so uh clearly the the advice for
everyone watching is don't panic and try
and stay the course I think you've also
answered I just want to mention that Tim
you also sent a question to us very
similar so I think that's just been
answered I'm extremely worried I'm due
to retire in January I see my fund has
lost approximately 10 should I delay so
so hopefully Tim that answers your
question
um let's uh come back to you Jamie um
Bob is asking if our pensions fail who
do we turn to
um again just to Echo what what Tom said
and and Claire as well is that the it
depends what sort of pension you're
describing here if it's a defined
benefit pension there are Protections in
place that even if the company that is
providing it goes best then you're
you're still going to receive your your
pension that's for people who who have a
fixed return and they're gonna they know
they're gonna get there are other people
which is probably and there are many of
them who just have uh pensions that are
invested in stocks and so what you get
back in Future years will depend on how
the the assets in that in that portfolio
perform
um and I think the thing that is
important to recognize is that for those
people who are now reminded to look at
their pensions and see what they're
worth
there is a substantial Global element
here so most pensions are invested in
countries all across the globe in a big
selection of different assets and Global
Equity prices Global bond prices have
all fallen and that's because uh central
banks like the fed the bank of England
the ECB they're all lifting rates to try
and fight inflation and that's pushing
down on asset values and that is
something which may which which may
persist for a very long time so I think
it's it's important to distinguish that
it's there's not there are things that
the government are doing which are
unhelpful to certainly to markets
um they're unlikely actually to be
having an immediate direct effect on on
pension parts that are invested globally
it's really there's other stuff going on
as well which is which is pushing those
values around and they may be quite
persistent trends
I mean what uh to all of you really I
mean
how can we allay people's fears who are
watching obviously we're trying our best
to do that by going to the nitty-gritty
and explain how this all works but
people are extremely worried you know
they've worked hard all their life
there's a cost of living crisis they've
put their money in for a rainy day as
we've always been told to you know get
your pension it should be safe and now
there's all this fear about pensions
anyone can come in really if you want to
answer that or
all we can do is reassure people so
they're part of the challenge of what's
happened here is that pensions in a way
have been caught in the crossfire of
much wider events and part of what's
been exposed here I think is people's
lack of understanding of Pensions and
how their pensions work and the Very
fact that their pensions are invested so
a lot of the questions I've been dealing
with today have been people who are
fundamentally confused that the value of
their pension could go down over the
short term now that's absolutely nothing
to do with what we're seeing at the
moment that's just the nature of
long-term investing now clearly nobody's
going to be popping any champagne corks
at the moment because things have been
very difficult but I think one of the
big challenges we need to get over here
is the fact that people just don't
understand stuff and if you've got to
keep driving home this message that
actually most of the time your pension
is going to be saved because in the
current circumstances that is absolutely
the case
yeah that that's great thank you I think
that's what sometimes when we have um
these question and answers with experts
and you're also knowledgeable it can be
quite overwhelming can't it and it's
just nice for people to understand as
you say a lot of people don't understand
how this stuff works and we are
constantly talking here at Sky News
certainly about the economy we're really
trying to explain to people how it all
works so let's move on then we've got um
more questions
um
should I Simon is asking should I
continue with extra payments into my
pension at this time slightly a
different question about
um but people still worried about
putting their payments in so Simon
Claire let's ask you Simon's asking
should he still continue with extra
payments at this time is that about
affordability
I guess it is really I I think truly it
is about affordability it's about the
cost of living as well
um we would always encourage people to
continue their continue their
contributions paying in in a fluctuating
Market can be just as good as paying in
if the market is is stable because
you're when you buy into these stocks
and shares as I said things fluctuate on
a day-to-day basis
um they call it pound cost average in
another horrible bunch of jargon that we
don't want to get into today but
basically it means by buying it on
different days you're spreading the risk
of buying a higher or lower rate and
therefore over the long term that Tom's
talked about that you can actually get a
real benefit from doing this so rather
than putting there and putting it in a
in a cash account and sitting there and
waiting until you suddenly see the
market going back up when you're likely
to not time it and try and put it in and
you've already missed out on the market
going back up putting it in on a regular
basis and getting your tax relief on a
regular basis really important because
that's actually why we're investing in
pensions in the first place is to get
that good tax relief can actually make a
really good long-term plan we always
look at I think all the cost of delay
and of course the delay is not doing
something today and how much would it
cost me if I then have to try and play
catch-up I'm trying to play catch up on
pensions can actually be quite difficult
because they you need to make sure
you've got enough earnings for tax money
if you need to make sure that you can
meet all the other requirements so I
would if if it was me and I could
continue to afford to do it then I would
be continuing personally to make those
contributions and take advantage
um on the current prices that you're
buying into the market at because we we
do hope and and generally we have to say
the market does go up in the long term
as we say these are very long-term
Investments okay
um let's take a question from Martin now
Martin you've written in saying the bank
of England are buying guilts from
Pension funds I understand there are
other tools they can use what are they
uh Jamie Rush
and so so the problem is that the the
Pension funds are having to sell some of
their assets and as to in this case it's
long-term guilts uh to be able to uh
post something which is called a margin
call and it's it's um it's it's
basically they buy insurance uh against
movements and asset prices and they have
to post a certain amount of clash rule
to be able to finance that so what
they're being uh that they're having to
sell these these these bonds and there's
no one who wants to buy them which means
that they're making huge losses and it
makes the problem worse the more they
have to sell more bonds and it's just
feeding in on itself so the bank is
trying to stop this this kind of cycle
this vicious cycle from establishing
Itself by being a buyer for these bonds
um they are doing that they could do it
for quite a long time if they if they
needed to I think
um to keep the floor under a floor under
prices and stop Pension funds these
particular Pension funds from from
becoming insolvent
um
it's one option there are some other
options
um the government itself could step in
and design a scheme to bail out Pension
funds so that the this this kind of
cycle doesn't doesn't persist that's one
other option the bank meeting could also
buy some of these bonds but also sell
some at different lower maturity so the
problem is very specifically located
around very long-term guilt so 20
30-year bonds that the government has
issued the banks could buy those but
sell some two-year or five-year bonds
and it'll probably be able to do that
without causing any dislocations at that
end of the market so the bank has
options
um it's for them it's just presentation
in Auckland because they don't like to
be printing money to buy to buy bonds
right
um this is an interesting one from Al
our public sector pensions safe
are they Tom
yes
um yes they are public sector pensions
uh uh the safest kind of pension that
you could possibly have because they're
they're backed up by the taxpayers so
provided the the UK as a nation state
doesn't go bust and if that happens then
we're all going to be in quite a lot of
trouble frankly then your your public
sector pensions should and and will be
safe in the same way that Define benefit
pensions in the private sector are going
to be safe they're safe but they're
they're extra safe because they're
backed by the UK as a country
fantastic okay
um uh this is from Anna and I'm going to
put it to Claire um Anna is asking I'm a
young person who has not yet started
paying into a pension fund is it even
worth starting to pay into a pension
scheme at the moment so good question
from Anna there Claire
great question
um but yes
um again we're back to that course of
delay you start now and you start small
and it gives you all that scope to build
up all those funds in those many years
until you get old and wise and and come
to retire
um it's really important to remember
though if you are employed and you're
earning ten thousand pounds a year your
employer should be putting you into a
workplace scheme the the important thing
with that is that they will make a
contribution too and if you choose not
to be a member they get to keep that
money
um so we're not saying that we don't
want them to keep that money but we're
saying we want them to put it in the
pension for you so that you get that
benefit it's in essence free money it's
extra salary that you will get if you
join your workplace pension scheme so
really important Auto enrollment was a
great invention brought in in 2012 and
has actually put so many more people
into pension savings so please do not uh
waste it do not waste that free money
and take it where it's available and if
you can afford to even put the smallest
amount away all that long-term saving
compound interest more horrible jargon
will continue to build those funds and
that you'll be in the market for a lot
longer and hopefully you know you will
outride all of this and and everything
uh will become great and you'll have a
wonderful retirement just because you
started sooner rather than later it
should in theory Cost You Less okay
that's brilliant advice there I think a
lot of people don't realize about
pension schemes at work as well I know I
didn't when I was much younger okay
we've um not not got long left and I
have two questions I'm going to put them
together
um they're kind of similar really
Russell is asking how after a short
period of Market time or can a fund even
be at risk and Jeremy is saying I know
pensions are a long-term project but
will they recover and increase in the
future
um they want to know that there's going
to be recovery Tom
so just gotta keep driving home this
point the Pension funds aren't at risk
um so there are specific issues with
Investments within defined benefit
pension schemes that have led to
Collateral calls so demands for cash
from those pension schemes but provided
the sponsor sitting behind Divine
benefit pension schemes is strong then
your pension will be safe and there's
the pension protection fund sitting
behind it now in terms of General market
turmoil we are if you're going to invest
for the long term you are going to
experience periods where things are
bumpy we've experienced it in 2016 with
the European Union referendum we
experienced it in 2020 with covid back
in 2007-2008 we had the great financial
crash these things are part and parcel
of investing and actually the
fluctuations we've seen in stock markets
and in the value of people's pensions
over the last two weeks two months and
nothing unusual all at all and I think
part of the challenge here is to educate
people on the fact that their money in a
pension normally is going to be invested
and so it's going to go up and down over
the short term with the aim of achieving
long-term growth so a big education
thank you Tom hopefully we've done that
tonight thank you so much for answering
all those questions I mean they were
they were similar in Parts but broad too
so that's great Tom Selby Jamie rush and
Claire Trott thanks very much indeed for
your expertise tonight answering your
questions